Known territory or what's exploring
unknown territory or what's not
explored,
the Trans transformation or the
dissolution of one into the other,
and then the reconstitution of that.
That's one of the election does,
right?
It's like,
okay,
we have our leader who's the person at
the top of the dominance hierarchy and
defines the nature of this particular
structure.
There's an election.
It's regulated chaos.
No one knows what's going to happen.
It's the death of the old king.
Bang.
We go into a chaotic state.
Everyone argues for awhile and then out
of that argument they produce a
consensus and Poof,
we're in a new state,
right?
That's the Meta story,
Order,
chaos order,
but it's partial order,
chaos,
reconstituted,
and revivified order.
That's the thing is that this order is
better than that order,
so there's progress and that's partly
why I think the idea of moral relativism
is wrong.
There's progress in moral order and it
was defined property by piaget.
The new moral order does everything.
The other moral,
the old moral order did and some
additional things.
That's what constitutes progress.
Now,
here's a.
here's a strange idea and we'll talk
about this more as we progress through
the class.
What's the ultimate in order?
Well,
it's not there,
so obviously because it can collapse and
it's not this because it can collapse
and so then you think,
well,
there's no ultimate order even though
there's progression,
but then you have to move it up one
level of abstraction.
What's the ultimate order doing this
willingness to do that?
That's the ultimate order,
right?
It's order at a different level of
analysis and you can see that's what's
represented in that idea.
That's what that idea means.
That's the Phoenix,
right?
The Phoenix is something that lives ages
and then allows itself to be consumed by
fire and then reemerge us and they
pulled.
Phoenix gets old and Burns and the new
phoenix reemergence,
and so the real phoenix is the thing
that's constant across those
transformations.
That's the union self.
That's what he meant.
The self is the element of the psyche
that remains intact across
transformations.
Yeah.
It's a bloody amazing idea.
That's for sure,
and you could think about that.
That's why you haven't claimed,
for example,
in ion primarily that Christ was a
symbol of the self that was his
consequence of decades of meditation on
the structure of Christianity because
it's the dying and resurrecting part of
the psyche that remains constant across
the the transformation.
So the ultimate order isn't to identify
with this.
That's your current state of being and
it isn't tied into fight with that
because,
well you can't by definition and it
isn't even to identify with that.
It's to let these things go as they need
to go.
That's a sacrifice and to allow this
continual process of transformation to
occur and part of that is the admission
that you're wrong.
And so partly what you're doing is at
micro levels and macro levels where are
you not what you could be and when you
realize that it'll take you apart a
little bit and burn you down to your
core a little bit and then allow you to
regenerate.
And if you do that continually,
the everything that you don't need burns
away.
Right?
And that's what this means.
You remember in Harry Potter,
you may remember that Harry goes down,
so in the second volume and in the
second movie,
Harry's at Harvard,
so it's the school where you learn how
to be magic because that's what you
really are,
and there's something that threatens the
school.
Well,
part of what threatens the school.
Evil,
right?
Voldemort.
That's one thing,
but at the same time,
it's also the snake that lurks
underneath.
It's the basilisk that that threatens
the school,
and so the Basilisk is the dragon,
and when the Basler looks at you,
then you're paralyzed because you're a
prey animal.
And if a Predator captures you in its
gaze,
you freeze.
And the reason you freeze is because
your body reacts to the Predator as
something that should turn you to stone
certain about that.
So what do you do about the bass list?
Well,
one thing you do is you run and hide,
but the other thing you do is go
confronted and insulator.
And that's what Harry Potter does now.
And what's interesting about him is he's
also touched by evil,
right?
And that means that he's an embodiment
of what you would regard as someone
who's integrated the shadow and without
that capacity,
isn't able to communicate,
say with snakes.
And that's not so good because since
there are snakes,
it's not such a bad idea to know how to
communicate with them and he goes down
into the underground,
right into the chaotic domain that's
underneath the school in order to find
the snake.
And it's layer.
Now,
if I remember correctly,
you can you tell me if I'm wrong,
it doesn't need go down through a
bathroom,
through a toilet.
Right?
Well,
so that's an indication of the union
dictum that where are you,
what you most,
what you need most is to be found where
you least want to look.
I had a client once who actually had a
dream like that.
He dreamt that he had to go into the
underground world through an outhouse.
Right?
Was very,
very interesting.
And it was an elaboration of precisely
this theme.
It's what you've thrown away as of
little value to you and maybe what you
hate and hold in contempt and fear is
exactly what you have to face if you
want to go down to the place where the
transformations occur.
So what happens in Harry Potter,
while this Bass licks his wandering
around paralyzing everyone who isn't
able to communicate with snakes and he
doesn't fight the basslink precisely.
It goes down into its layers,
the underground world,
and that what,
what down there is that snake has got a
Vra,
right?
His girlfriend,
that's her name,
right?
It's a,
it's a,
it's a variant of Virginia that's a
variant of virgin.
And the snake always has a virgin.
That's one of its characteristics,
right?
Like gold.
He goes down there to rescue her.
What happens to him?
He gets bit and he's going to die.
So what happens?
The Phoenix comes along and cries tears
into his wounds and charism.
And that's
so the idea is that what saves you in
the encounter with the snake is your
capacity to let things go and die and
come back to life.
Right?
It's so interesting a that that story's
told in that way,
in that series of volumes because the,
the,
the plot structure is perfect in a
mythological sense.
It's exactly right.
And the Phoenix APP actually happens to
be the pat of the main wizard,
which is also perfect.
It's exactly right.
So you know,
what's his name?
The WHO,
who?
Dumbledore.
Yeah.
He's basically,
for all intents and purposes,
God the father and his pat,
his,
his close ally is the thing that can die
and that transforms well.
You can see the echoes of Christian
thought in that,
but that isn't exactly right.
It's the Christian thought and the
mythological substructure upon which the
Harry Potter volume is based,
are drawing from the same underlying
pool of ideas and symbols and they're
universally accessible and you can tell
that because if they weren't,
that book wouldn't have sold how many
million copies,
how many million copies did it sell,
and the movies.
If it's unbelievably overwhelmingly
powerful,
she got kids to read 600 page books,
like multiple volumes lining up for
them.
You got to ask yourself why silly
stories about magical orphans.
It's like,
well,
maybe not.
Maybe people aren't so stupid,
and certainly if they happen to be
reading relatively complex books,
attributing that to stupidity seems to
be rather counterproductive.